alors nous sommes en baie de saint
brieuc j'ai une question une question à
vous poser combien parmi vous se sont
déjà promené plus d'une demi heure
d'affilée sur les sentiers douaniers
pour observer la baie de saint brieuc
parmi vous ça fait pas mal de monde
combien parmi vous ont déjà navigué plus
d'une demi heure d'affilée sur la mer en
baie de saint brieuc
on voit qu'il ya des gens d'ici un écran
bien parmi vous ont passé plus d'une
demi heure dans l'eau dans la baie de
saint brieuc
c'est pas mal car là c'est pas varié
quand même un public qui est assez
initiés mais il ya quand même un bon
trois quarts de la salle qui a priori
n'a jamais mis la tête sous l'eau ou
tout au moins pendant une bonne
demi-heure pour explorer les fonds
marins est en fait moi il m'est arrivé
la même chose
je suis né à toulon j'ai été bercé par
les histoires du commandant cousteau ma
grand-mère travailler à l'arsenal de
toulon donc elle le croisé et puis
j'entendais parler de lui j'ai été bercé
quand j'étais petit par toutes les
histoires du commandant cousteau la
calypso tintin et le secret de la
licorne
spirou les hommes but tout ça me
passionnait et j'ai mis vingt ans alors
que j'habitais à toulon j'ai passé mon
enfance et j'ai retourné toutes mes
vacances avant de mettre la tête dans
l'eau et c'est parce que j'ai commencé à
mener mais mes copains de lycée et de
fac
là où j'avais passé mon enfance qu'un
jour l'un d'eux m'a dit mais c'est
drôlement beau là bas si on allait
plonger ça n'était jamais venu à l'idée
en fait pour moi c'était pas accessible
et pourtant lors si on si on prend un
peu de recul
notre planète elle est plutôt bleu que
verte ou couleur terre et sept planètes
sept planètes
quand on pense que les premières
explorations sous-marines date
certainement de 3000 à 5000 ans avant
jésus-christ or il est de fait l'état
qui a toujours eu des pêcheurs des gens
qui paie chez les huîtres qui allait
charger des perles et puis aussi des
choses pour se nourrir les premiers
appareils pour aller au découragement de
sous-marins c'est des premières gravures
on à alexandre le grand ver 325 avant
jésus-christ qui a fabriqué après lyon
un tonneau dans lequel il aurait passé
plusieurs heures
et puis on a eu après il a fallu
attendre longtemps de xvième où le xviie
siècle pour avoir les premiers
travailleurs sous marin dans des cloches
et
donc qu'ils travaillaient à une
profondeur d'une vingtaine de mètres en
moyenne 20 mètres c'est la profonde en
moyenne de la baie de saint brieuc 25
mètres à peu près ensuite on a eu plus
tôt fantasmer mais qui s'appuyait quand
même sur les découvertes de l'époque et
sur les scaphandres de l'époque jules
verne qui nous a raconté plein d'
aventure qui se passait sous les mers et
plus près de nous au xxème siècle en
1962 exactement les projets pré
continent les premières personnes à
habiter sous la mer pendant plusieurs
jours sept jours là on voit sur la photo
albert falcou avec qui j'ai eu le
plaisir et l'honneur de plongée surtout
plaisir qui passe sa tête par avec l'eau
il faut imaginer que près continent
c'est un an après le premier homme dans
l'espace
61e youri gagarine qui fait un petit
tour dans l'espace qui revient sur terre
et sait 1962 qu'on a eu des premières
personnes dans l'océan vraiment pour
virer toujours pareil là le question ici
diogène 10 mètres de profondeur cng dit
m c'est à peu près la distance qui nous
sépare du milieu de la salle ici lors
plus proche de nous dans les projets
tout à l'heure on évoquait si orbiteur
le projet de jacques rougerie une grande
station scientifique qui va dériver sur
les flots et qui est un des projets du
début du xxième siècle et donc ce projet
c'est un vaisseau qui fait 60 m 2 aux 30
mètres sous l'eau 30 mètres au dessus
mais on en est ne toujours pas avoir de
grandes stations scientifiques comme on
en orbite aujourd'hui autour de la terre
le monde sous marin reste très très
inaccessibles
alors si on replonge un petit peu dans
cet océan
donc si je pars de la surface bon la
plupart d'entre vous y en a pas mal qui
connaissent à priori par ici
et si on prend un petit peu de
profondeur ici voyage pilotes
j'ai deux petits sous-marins ici que je
pilote avec mon smartphone c'est ce que
nous permettent les technologies
d'aujourd'hui je suis dans le virtuel
alors le virtuel pour comme base le
virtuel ne s'oppose pas au réel le
virtuel c'est ce qui n'est pas dans
l'instant où dans le lieu d'accord si je
visite un château de manière virtuelle
il n'est pas imaginaire ce château il
est simplement soit je n'y suis pas et
je me projette d'une manière ou d'une
autre
et je le visite à une autre époque on
dit par exemple que l'arbre est
virtuellement présent dans la graine
donc je vais descendre avec mont
sous-marin et quand j'observe en fait
une chose que certains d'entre vous
doivent savoir les océans produit 50% de
l'oxygène que l'on respire entre 50 et
60% les océans c'est en surface deux
tiers de la surface de notre planète
mais si aussi si on tient compte du
volume parce qu'en fait les espèces qui
vivent le plancton et toutes les autres
espèces se répartissent dans la
profondeur donc dans le volume c'est en
fait 90 % de l'espace habitable de la
planète
90% des transports qui se font sur la
planète se font par les océans et sur
ces 90 % en fait de notre planète on
n'en connaît que 10% la petite boule que
vous voyez sur l'écran c'est ce qu'on
connaît seulement des océans aujourd'hui
au début du 21e siècle et ses océans
avant même d'avoir su et d'avoir pu
utiliser tout ce qu'ils peuvent nous
offrir en termes de pharmacologie en
terme de nourriture en termes de
l'histoire de notre de notre révolution
on est en train de les détruire tiers
comme c'est en ce moment c'est 100 de
déchetterie énorme
on commence à trouver des traces plutôt
inquiétante de plastique dans les
poissons dans les mollusques etc
et pourtant ces océans toujours
j'insiste là dessus sont tellement
inconnu qu'on a été par exemple capable
de retrouver un poisson le coelacanthe
qu'on croyait disparue depuis 65
millions d'années date des derniers
fossiles qu'on a trouvé on l'a retrouvé
à 120 m de fond au sud est de l'afrique
donc 120 mètres c'est la distance que
moi je parcours pour aller prendre non
pas le matin chez mon boulanger est en
fait il a fallu attendre la fin la fin
du xxème siècle le début début du xxème
pour retrouver ce poisson qui n'était
qu'à 120 m 2 nous finalement est resté
caché jusqu'à maintenant alors quand je
me suis mis à la plongée moi je me
rappelais d'une phrase du commandant
cousteau qui est qui a toujours
raisonner un petit peu qui
qui était de dire qu en fait des gens
protègent et respecte ce qu'ils aiment
et donc si on veut qu'ils aiment la mer
il faut autant les émerveiller que les
éduquer donc quand j'ai commencé la
plongée si on fait un petit retour en
arrière
la première chose que j'ai voulu faire
c'était sortir un petit peu de cette
formation qui était très militaire en
fait parce que la plongée on travaille
sur les tables de plongée de la marine
nationale par exemple et je me suis dit
bon qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire pour
changer un petit peu notre angle de vue
sur la plongée la rendre un peu plus
ludique
alors j'ai commencé à essayer de faire
des logiciels pour la formation on
apprend beaucoup de physique pour la
formation est donc là ce que vous voyez
c'est le le premier logiciel que j'ai
fait quand j'étais étudiant donc c'était
86 lors c'était éducatif par contre
c'était pas vraiment de merveilleux suis
pas si on est un petit peu le voilà on
était et est quand même loin du résultat
alors ce qui se passait c'est qu'à
l'époque c'était très confidentiel dans
un club à l'époque internet c'était
internet la version 1 0
on savait pas qu'il y aurait la deux et
la trois plus tard et ainsi de suite
internet 1 0 c'était des pages
connectées entre elles rappelé le les
liens hypertextes j'ai une page cliquer
sur un lien ça m'amène sur notre page
ça s'est arrêté là une belle médiathèque
mais ça s'arrêtait là donc impossible de
communiquer impossible de diffuser un
logiciel par internet
et puis de le partager suite à ça bah
années 90 2000 etc sont arrivés les
premiers jeux ils sont arrivés les
premiers 3d sur les consoles de jeux sur
les ordinateurs lors des jeux qui
parlait du monde sous-marin qui commence
à se l'approprier ce monde sous marin
mais des jeux sans éthique souvent et
sans aucun réalisme
la plupart du temps il faut tuer des
requins mutants la race à abattre est
absolument innommable et dans le même
temps on a aussi alors que depuis 1977 à
peu près au l'ifremer par exemple été
capable de faire la cartographie 3d des
fonds marins google s'approprie aussi
cette cette technologie et commence dans
la version 5 de google earth de
présenter les océans en 3d à visiter
mais comme vous pouvez le voir aussi
là dessus on à la 3d on a les vrais
fonds marins mais finalement ce n'est
toujours pas dans l'émerveillement
c'est toujours pas de vie qu'elle soit
animale ou végétale
entre temps il s'était passé une chose
c'est que le web était devenu 2 0 donc
ce n'était plus que des pages connectées
entre elles s'étaient aussi des gens
connectés entre eux le symbole c'est
facebook les réseaux sociaux on connecte
les gens et ce sont les gens qui
deviennent les médias ont finalement les
meilleurs diffuseur d'information ce
sont les utilisateurs
donc je me suis penché donc vingt ans
après sur mes petits logiciels qui
n'avaient pas forcément forcément de
deux futurs je faisais ce qu'on
pourraient pas réinvestir ça avec ces
nouveaux réseaux sociaux pour en faire
quelque chose et là je suis tombé dans
un musée un petit peu sur internet je
suis tombé à l'époque 2006 2007 sur
second life
univers virtuels en ligne en fait c'est
du ce et du web mais au lieu d'avoir des
lignes de texte et des photos vous êtes
un petit personnage un avatar vous
promener dans un univers en 3d et vous
interagissez avec des gens mais des
vrais gens qui sont derrière et là je me
dis le virtuel finalement qui s'opposent
pauwels et en même temps on fait comme
si quand on est dans le virtuel
hélas cette histoire avec paddy la
fédération de plongée américaine mon
premier contrat gelé signé avec eux en
bossant dans mon grenier en fait un jour
un petit avatar qui arrivent tous
chevelu et qui va parler avec mon avatar
avec nos claviers en anglais dans le
texte et qui me dit tiens c'est
intéressant j'ai vu des outils de
simulation de plongée est ce qu'on
pourrait pas en faire quelque chose non
je n'ai pas qui je m'adressais puis il
se présente au bout d'un moment j'ai eu
john kinsella vice-présidente paddy
america donc en californie moi j'étais
un peu de neuf à londres et dans vanier
donc ok on bosse ensemble et puis ce
premier projet donc m'a permis de me
lancer
hélas ce que vous voyez sur cette image
ce sont des gens alors j'aurais pu vous
dire qu'il était derrière ces avatars
mais il y avait un australien il peut y
avoir un japonais en espagnol en
français alors ça posait des problèmes
des fois sur les heures de sommeil mais
on se regroupait et les gens discutaient
entre eux et on parlait de plongée et là
on avait déjà des premiers retours mais
j'ai des gens qui m'ont envoyé des mails
des mails les premiers plaisirs de gens
qui disaient je n'avais jamais plongé et
grâce à ce qui a été développé dans
second life je suis allé faire mon
baptême de plongée je suis en train de
passer me niveau et voilà je
je me suis lancée en fait après dans
second life en était toujours pas sur du
réel
on reste quand même sur de l'imaginaire
donc je me suis rapproché d'un garçon
qui s'appelle alain dîner ce qui a un
projet qui s'appelle 18 à l'océan
et puis je me suis rapproché de lui pour
essayer de voir ce qu'on pouvait faire
de ce qu'on pouvait aller récupérer sur
le monde réel pour le ramener dans dans
ses mandants 3d et on est allé vous avez
vu que les moyens du bord cartographier
des récifs coralliens
on a fait une expérience comme ça en
egypte donc à la main avec des petits
dessins des petits crowbar n'y a pas
besoin de beaucoup de technique en fait
on fait appel à ce que sont capables de
faire les plongeurs l'intérêt c'est ça
c'est de prendre chacun d'entre nous
d'entre vous comme étant des capteurs
environnementaux
et puis dans d'emmagasiner les données
qu'ils peuvent prendre et l'idée de ce
projet une fois qu'on a scanné un récif
en 3d c'est de pouvoir le ramener à la
piscine municipale par exemple le
ramener à l'école et pouvoir faire
plonger les enfants qui ne pourront pas
forcément à voyager dans des contrées
lointaines pour différents différents
problèmes ou de coups d'accessibilité ou
de protection aussi si ce sont des zones
protégées
mais on va pouvoir faire un peu
découvrir en ayant une immersion
corporelle on est dans l'eau à la
piscine avec le visuel couplé et bien ça
fonctionne certes le cerveau se fait
avoir assez facilement même si on est
juste devant un petit écran on a quelque
chose qui commence à se passer on
commence à avoir un peu d'émerveillement
et après le coelacanthe que vous avez vu
au début avec laurent ballesta
émerveillés devant ce poisson qu'ils
découvrent pour la première fois ce
c'est là quand on la modéliser en 3d et
on l'a transporté comme ça dans un
masque de arrêté virtuel oculus rift qui
vous permet quand vous le mettez sur vos
yeux de regarder partout autour de vous
et de vous retrouver dans
l'environnement vous êtes immergés
l'information est autant de vous cette
fois et ce masque on l'a promené dans
plusieurs salons salon de la plongée
festival mondial de l'image sous-marine
les gens étaient tous s'amuser
émerveillé un petit peu des images là il
ya un jour il ya un petit enfant très un
garçon d'une quinzaine d'années très
lourdement handicapée à la fois aux
moteurs et physique qui étaient là avec
ses parents sa mère dit
il peut essayer alors évidemment qui
peut essayer c'est justement fait pour
c'est pour donner accès à ceux qui ne
peuvent pas d'amis de masques
il est resté un bon moment comme ça à
regarder autour de lui et quand ils en
avaient le masque
il avait un sourire un beau sourire qui
m'émeut toujours d'ailleurs et sa maman
a dit il avait 15 ans a dit je n'ai
jamais vu sourire comme ça ça c'était un
moment assez fort parce qu'on s'est dit
là sans le vouloir en fait on commençait
à toucher un petit peu ce transport de
l'émerveillement on entend parler et ça
c'était vraiment un bon moment et je me
suis dit en fait ce qu'on faisait en
seconde life on faisait comme si c'était
nous les acteurs ont fait comme si et
nous on est juste des techniciens en
fait condamner en balbutiement de tous
ces outils
à l'époque des frères lumière quand ils
ont présenté le train entre en gare de
la ciotat
le public est parti en courant ils ont
peur de se faire écraser par le train et
en fait on avait des techniciens qui est
mis au point une appareil de projection
aujourd'hui ces technologies sont prêts
à partir dans le grand public et surtout
prête à partir vers des gens qui vont
être artiste et qui vont savoir les
utiliser cette technologie
elles sont devenus le standard donc
imaginer ce qu'on va pouvoir en faire
quand nous on a été capable de
transporter les motions de laurent
ballesta jusqu'à ce garçon comme ça donc
cette histoire aussi et c'est l'histoire
de tout le monde parce que ce qu'on va
montrer aux gens il sait la faire de
tout le monde et tout le monde peut
devenir aujourd'hui comme j'ai tout à
l'heure à capteur environnementale quand
on plonge merci quand on se promène
quand on est en kayak
on peut mettre sur des sites de science
participative on peut mettre les
informations et participer comme ça à
des choses collectives donc le web
aujourd'hui il est dans sa version 3 0
donc quand on tient compte de toutes ces
choses qui évoluent et à cette vitesse
le web 3 0 ce sont des objets qui sont
connectés entre eux c'est un peu non
seulement vous avez les informations à
la grande médiathèque vous avez les gens
qui sont connectés entre eux qui peuvent
interagir
vous avez ces informations que peut
prendre qu'on peut prendre à droite et à
gauche qu'on peut amalgamer mais vous
pouvez aussi rendre communicant
n'importe lequel les objets aujourd'hui
qui nous entoure par exemple ici vous
avez avec les lunettes google glace qui
vous permettent d'augmenter la réalité
qui vous entourent la réelle et
augmenter ses lunettes pour vous
permettre de faire sortir d'un livre qui
existe déjà
les espèces sous marines en 3d
vous donnez surtout des liens vers des
informations en ce qui les concerne leur
protection ou non la manière de les
pêcher dans quelle zone on peut les
pêcher et aussi vous renvoyer sur les
sites de science participative de genre
comme l' agence de l'eau la fondation
albert ii de monaco des gens qui
travaillent comme ça sur l'agrégation de
données
donc aujourd'hui on en est là c'est à
dire que vous tous ici présents
vous pouvez jouer un rôle dans une
communauté qui va permettre de remonter
les informations à des scientifiques
mais pas que dans le monde de la plongée
c'est valable pour le tourisme pour
l'industrie dans énormément de domaines
et surtout vous allez pouvoir aussi
aller voir le résultat de ce que vous
avez fait et de ce à quoi vous avez
contribué
aujourd'hui avec mon petit sous peu un
petit sous-marin que je pilote ici
toujours dans mon écran il suffit
simplement d'un petit bout de carton
comme ça voyez je mets mon téléphone
dedans et en fait je vais aller visiter
mon environnement virtuel et je vais
pouvoir voir peut être éventuellement ce
sur quoi travailles des scientifiques à
partir de données comme moi je leur ai
fourni ou des pistes que je leur ai
indiqué donc voila un petit peu on en
est et ce qui est amusant c'est c'est
cette technologie la deux le petit
masque stéréoscopique mais jules verne
il a peut être utilisé ça parce que
c'est la fin du 19ème c'est le
stéthoscope de holtz s'est simplement de
lentilles et puis à l'époque on mettait
deux cartes postales
il y avait une photo prise d'un côté une
photo prise de l'autre une pour chaque
oeil et avec ça en reprise et le relief
et on n'en menait déjà fin du xixème
siècle les gens de manière virtuelle
dans des paysages qu'ils ne
connaissaient pas voilà donc un petit
état des lieux deux ou peuvent nous
mener ces technologies et surtout de
votre contribution est à vous de vous y
intéresser de vous lancer là dedans
merci